[Music]
foreign welcome to the pretty intense
podcast if you could please hit the
Subscribe button I would really
appreciate it today on the show is David
Kipping David is the associate professor
of astronomy at Columbia University and
the director of pool world's Lab at
Columbia University I love the Universe
I love the nature of reality I'm
eternally fascinated probably eternally
is the right word because it will we
ever get the answers can we are we
really even programmed to be able to
answer the biggest questions I'm not
really sure but that's what we delved
into today and explored everything from
our own planet to the universe to our
galaxy AI the types of civilizations
extraterrestrials of course
getting off planet and then literally
just like what do we hope like what do
we hope is our reality because there's
so many potentials and I think that you
know we kind of spun around on this sort
of idea that we can even have these
thoughts that we we think some pretty
big things we feel like we know some
pretty big things and and why is that
and what does that mean for us as humans
and what does it mean for our future
this is all about the nature of reality
our universe and our orientation and
where we're going and even where we've
come from David is a just a brilliant
guy that is a really good teacher so if
anybody is interested in learning more
about the stuff that we talked about
today he has a YouTube channel called
cool worlds get into science science is
cool come on be a nerd with us
um us meaning at least I'm fascinated
and he knows the answers so check this
out please hit the Subscribe button the
thumbs up and let me know what you think
in the comments all great athletes have
one thing in common they take care of
their bodies it's something that we do
from a young age whether we work out the
food that we eat how we prepare our mind
this is all part of becoming a great
athlete and one thing that I do every
single morning is I drink ag1 I do it
before I have coffee I do it before I
eat any food I really feel like for me
it's helped my gut health it's made my
stomach just feel like less bloated and
more calm throughout the day it handles
all food so much better I'm putting like
75 high quality ingredients into my body
first thing in the day which makes a
huge difference even if I'm traveling I
use the travel packs I was in Europe for
six weeks every single day I put ag1
into my body so if a comprehensive
solution is what you need from your
supplement routine then ag-1 is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to drinkag1.com pretty
intense that's drink ag1.com
pretty intense check it out you research
the stuff but it's just so fascinating
to me and always has been like since I
was a young kid it's just I feel like so
fascinated by the universe and how
things work and what our place in it is
I wonder like what's your why like why
why research the things that you do and
what do you hope to find yeah I mean
maybe similar to you all my life it's
been one of those burning questions I've
as a child I remember lying in the grass
looking up at the sky looking at the
stars and just wondering what else was
out there and you know it's unusual
because I think at school we're told to
pursue careers that lead to real jobs
right so you should become an engineer
you should use your math to do that or
go into Finance or something like this
or a lawyer but I think um I was lucky
to have mentors when I was young who
realized that I was capable of it and
there was a career path for me to pursue
my passions which was physics and
astronomy and I I pursued those
questions ever since and it's always
felt like doing a hobby you know if I
was doing another job
as I'm sure happens to many of the
people I think I would still be doing
this on the side and the burning
question for me is just to really answer
are we alone how does the universe work
what else is out there it's it's just
within my soul to want to answer those
questions
you feel like you're trying to prove it
correct that we're not alone or you're
or you think we might be and you're
trying to prove it that we are not like
what do you what is your orientation in
that mission good yeah I'm glad you
asked that because people come in with a
lot of pre-loaded uh expectations and
judgments and decisions on this question
and as a scientist we have to think
about what are we trying to do in
science we're trying to figure out truth
objective truth and really that means
letting go of your personal beliefs your
personal desires and wants and in fact
trying to consciously leave those on the
side as much as possible so I really as
a scientist when I'm asked this as a
scientist I always say I don't know that
is that it that is not made the answer
that is very satisfying to hear because
we're used to scientists being able to
tell us the answer to all these
questions in life you know why does the
world spin every 24 hours why does the
sun rise why is the sunset what causes
rain Cycles now having all these answers
but for this question we really don't
know and I think it's just more honest
to say that we have good arguments to
think that we're not alone you can
certainly put forward a very convincing
argument to that case but you can also
put forward some pretty good arguments
to the contrary and so I don't want to
prejudge it my job as a scientist is to
look clearly with open eyes at the data
and try to figure out the truth and
sometimes that that does mean because
like I'm sure many of the listeners here
we want there to be life out there right
many of us feel that way some don't but
many of us feel that way we kind of wish
that there was someone else out there
um and you have to almost push that
aside and and work against it whenever
you see evidence that suggests this
could be life
we have to sort of take a step back
breathe and remember our own biases and
try to correct for those so I think
about that question very actively as a
scientist as to how to be fair and to be
clear-minded and objective which is
ultimately our job
what would it mean if we
were alone
and what would it mean if we weren't
it would I think it would be at least
for me it'd be pretty earth-shattering
right to to hear that Discovery either
way I think it would be super shocking
if we were alone super yeah I think a
lot of people feel that way and strange
enough it would probably be impossible
to ever establish that right so I if I
and that's kind of a curious nature of
that problem you can never basically
disprove life and that's that's a very
weird thing about aliens so one of the
recent research papers that I'm working
on actually points this out there are
three fundamental problems with looking
for aliens one is they can explain
everything so you could say why is the
sky blue that's because if aliens did it
they they flew in their spacecraft and
they sprayed Blues spray paint in the
sky and that's why the sky is blue and
some people might be satisfied with that
as an answer
um and then you could say well uh
another problem with them is that they
can evade everything so you might say
hey I saw a UFO on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday so I'll rock up and try to sit
with you on Thursday and I don't see it
and so my conclusion would be you were
wrong but you know you might defend that
and say well you know they don't come
every night sometimes you know they
don't feel like coming and so they're
infinitely evasive they could always
evade detection I think a more pointed
exampler is looking at Mars like we have
been driving Rovers all over the surface
of Mars for years trying to look for
signs of life we don't see anything but
we still can't disprove absolutely that
Mars does not have life may be buried
under this rock that we've just not
turned over or underneath the surface or
in some place we've not yet checked and
that's always going to be true no matter
how much even when we have Martian bases
Martian colonists trudging all over the
surface we still won't be absolutely
sure that there isn't some kind of Life
on that planet that just has been missed
thus far so that's an unusual feature
most uh scientific hypotheses do not
have that as a feature that they are
infinitely evasive and and also you know
subject to the to the whims of the alien
right the alien might be shy right and
so it could just not want to make
contact with you so both those things
are very unusual and you know it does
mean that I think coming back to your
question I think it's impossible that
we'll ever prove we are alone but I
think we could amass growing evidence
that we are at least unusual and very
very rare perhaps that I mean we already
have some evidence that that is true we
look out into the universe we do not see
stars that are engineered we do not see
giant machines orbiting Stars we do not
see galaxies that have been converted
into giant structures so as far as we
picked out everything about the universe
appears totally consistent with a fully
natural explanation
that does not mean there were no aliens
out there but it means they never get to
that point or at least they very rarely
get to that point where they start
engineering the universe and galaxies
and stars themselves and we have pretty
good data in that we know like one out
of a hundred thousand stars we've
surveyed that is not true that's an
interesting data point but again it
doesn't disprove that they're out there
in some what about the other hundred
thousand stars you need to go to a
million stars to really disprove this so
it might be impossible to have a
disprove it on the other hand let's say
we did hit a success and tomorrow we
discover you know compelling evidence
everybody's convinced that we have life
out there which I think would be
pretty amazing for many of us
it has the potential to unite Humanity
in so many ways right we'd start we'd
stop seeing divisions between countries
and borders and boundaries and we'd
start to see that we are just one people
on this fragile Little Rock floating
through space and there's all these
other people out there who are just
waiting for us to join the conversation
and to just grow up a little bit perhaps
and I think that would be transformative
to us and that is totally possible there
it's very possible there is still a
galactic Club out there who are waiting
for something to happen on this planet
to believe that we are worthy of
detection or worthy of communication and
we certainly can't rule that out either
the Galactic Federation I think it was
yeah I mean I interview a lot of people
are also very sort of spiritual and
esoteric in their thinking and you know
they talk about the Galactic Federation
they talk about it there's many people
I've talked to that that say that but
whether it's true or not obviously you
know the kind of proof that we're
looking for I think that's the thing I
always get a little stunk on is like
when we say there's no proof when we
can't explain how structures are built
we can't explain their mathematical sort
of superiority we can't explain their
orientation with the Stars we can't
explain certain things in the sky we
can't explain circuit certain you know
CIA secret programs that have existed
since the 50s and 60s and probably maybe
even earlier
um but we we can't explain these things
and this to me feels like some of the
proof
yeah it's it's easy to inject aliens
into that which we cannot yet explain
and and there is a very long history of
doing that
um and you you give some good examples I
think uaps are obviously the most sort
of poignant example in many people's
minds right now here is clearly a
phenomena that we have pretty good
evidence at this point there's something
going on and you know Pilots are clearly
seeing something and we don't understand
what it is one hypothesis I would say is
that it is alien visitation I would not
accept that that is the only hypothesis
on the table at this point I think there
are alternatives and this is such a a
major claim I think it deserves real
confidence before we before we go
gung-ho that this is the absolute
solution but there is a historical
present and that's why I'm sort of have
trepidation about injecting aliens here
there is many many cases where we have
said there's something we don't
understand it's aliens one of the most
famous examples actually happened with
Mars that we talked about earlier so go
back to 150 years ago there was a very
famous astronomer called Percival Lowell
who now uh he commissioned the Lowell
observatories in Arizona with his
inheritance he was an industrialist but
he got really into astronomy and so in
his later life he built his own
Observatory and he was obsessed with
Mars he was obsessed with it because at
the time it was recently discovered that
Mars had polar ice caps so you can kind
of see it if you if you get a you know a
few inch telescope or even a good pair
of binoculars and you look at Mars
you'll be able to see these little
whitish blue regions on the top and the
bottom and so scientists when they saw
that they thought wow if there's ice
that means there's water it looks just
like the Earth in terms of this like
little ball of rock hanging in the sky
so potentially there's life there and
Lowell had sort of you know talked about
pre-judgment he had prejudged there was
life there he was convinced even wrote
books saying
um it is assured that Marsh that Mars
has life in it as you know that the
Pope's Catholic that kind of stuff so he
was just totally convinced that of
course it's stupid to pretend that Mars
doesn't have life on it which is the
same kind of argument that we often hear
people today say well of course there's
life in the Galaxy like how how could
there not be it was the same kind of
thing and it's not unreasonable to to
suggest it's possible that Mars has life
on Earth and so when he started to look
at it very closely he started to see
these these streaks these lines across
Mars and so to him the obvious
conclusion as a pre-indust in an
industrial area he was seeing canals go
up all across the Across America at the
time so he concluded then the canal
systems what else could do this what
else could make lines across a planet
except for Canal systems and so he was
convinced there was a canal building
Martian civilization on Mars and and for
years we thought that was true I mean
for you or many people thought that was
true they were convinced it must be true
because personal law is very famous from
it said it was so and of course years
later we realized that actually most of
them were mirages they were caused by
distortions in the telescopes and
Atmospheric effects
and then there are some geological
features of course which also caused
this Linea they're called across the
across the planet but none of it was
canals of course we know that absolutely
we've put we've put you know movers
roaming around we know there's no Canal
civilization there
um but it was it was a classic case of
we see something we don't understand
and we put aliens there and you know
it's God of the gaps and we've done that
for Millennia why what causes the sun to
rise must be a god what causes uh the
planets to go around the Sun that must
be a god what causes the water to fall
from the sky that must be the god of
rain the god of thunder and and we did
that for a long time because we just
couldn't explain it and we're doing kind
of the same thing and that's what
worries me with aliens it's a it's such
a it's like a Band-Aid that can explain
everything so we just stick it on and we
forget to engage our brains a little bit
and really go through all the
possibilities dark energy and dark
matter which can't explain that there's
something there let's just call it dark
right I mean yeah that's that's a that's
an interesting comparison
um Dark Energy I would I would agree to
some degree feels that way uh dot
matching dark energy they often get
thrown together like they're both dark
they're the same dark something dark X
dark y so they must be kind of the same
thing they're very very different we
know almost nothing at all about dark
energy and so I kind of agree with you
that it is a Band-Aid in that way to
sort of EX there's something there that
we can't explain so just call it dark
energy we have some physical motivation
to think Dark Energy should exist if you
go to Quantum Theory and you look at
empty space you do predict that there
should be this bubbling froth of foam of
energy just popping into existence and
that vacuum energy is sort of what we
think could explain Dark Energy there's
huge discrepancies between what Dark
Energy we observe in the universe versus
what quantum theory predicts
that's a giant problem with dark matter
it's a little bit different because we
have multiple independent lines of
evidence for this stuff and it really is
just invisible stuff it's called Dark
Matter it should be called invisible
matter that'd be a much better name you
know you we the initial evidence was
taken by Vera Rubin a famous woman
astronomer who you know is now we've got
a uh should have had a Nobel Prize given
to her but I suspect wasn't because she
was a woman but she discovered dark
matter in in early evidence of rotation
of galaxies there is now going to be a
telescope named after her so fortunately
the Vera Rubin telescope it was
previously called lsst it's an eight
meter U.S telescope that we're building
one of the largest telescopes in the
world this could be named after her so
I'm pleased to see that happen to get
some credit to her
um but yeah we started to see that
evidence very early on from rotating
galaxies they're basically rotating too
fast so if you you know think about kids
on a on a roundabout on America round as
they they're clinging on for dear life
to hold on right and if they let go
they'll just fly off if they spin fast
enough and the same thing's basically
happening to galaxies the vast majority
of galaxies are spinning way too quick
to hold on to their Stars the
centrifugal force should be basically
flying them off so there must be
something holding on to that matter yeah
it could be that our theory of gravity
is wrong and that was a very compelling
counter argument for for a long time but
as we've accrued more and more
observations we have independent lines
of evidence such as gravitational
lensing so if you look at it you may
have seen this in the first James Webb
Space Telescope photos
there was this beautiful photo I forget
the name exactly of the image but it was
looking at a very very distant part of
the universe and you could see the
galaxies warped into kind of like a
fisheye lens you kind of see this
warping around the central region but
there was nothing there so somehow light
is passing through this region
and getting to our eyes so it must be
something that's transparent
and yet that transparent stuff is also
bending the light in other words it must
have gravity so there's invisible
bending stir so which is like another
completely independent and very
compelling evidence there is just
something there that we can't see and to
me that makes perfect sense why should
we expect that all matter in the
universe is stuff that we can see that's
kind of
um almost arrogant to think that should
be true like it's certainly quite
possible there's plenty of light that we
cannot we cannot see so I think there's
there's multiple times I feel much
better about dark matter it's not a
closed case I think uh we we are we
haven't completely removed the the
alternative theory of a modified theory
of gravity
with dark energy that's a big mystery
and there's lots to say about this you
know there's a crisis in cosmology right
now where there's a lot of disagreement
about dark energy that's a really
interesting open case I think Dark
Matter was starting to close in
but it's still not solved there either
you're saying that based on the size of
the sun and the energy that it has or
the size of that Galaxy that it
shouldn't be able to hold the planets
exoplanets the
it shouldn't be able to hold what it
holds based on its right rotation but
you're saying that might not be true
you're saying that's not maybe not true
the actual how fast it's spinning
because of this
because of the warping or you're saying
that that the dark matter is holding it
and that is an element that we just
don't understand how it can spin the way
it does and and keep everything
intact yeah let me try and let me try to
explain another way yeah there's
definitely you're on the right track
there so
um let's imagine we're talking about the
Galaxy but let's talk about our solar
system just from a solar system doesn't
really have much dark matter in it but
let's just take that as a as a case
example Mercury Goes Around The Sun It's
the closest planet and it actually the
closer you are to the Sun the faster you
orbit around it's kind of the same as a
penny drop you know those charity Penny
drops where you throw the coin kind of
goes around so as it gets closer it
speeds up as it goes down same thing
with planetary orbits and gravitational
orbits in general so Mercury is moving
pretty quick but what if we observed it
to be moving uh too fast it was moving
even faster than than what we currently
measure it to be there may be two or
three times faster that'd be very
personal because as far as we can tell
the the it should just fly off in a
straight line right because if you if
you put speed boosters on the back of
mercury and you you pushed it off and it
would just fly off on a tangent
basically and just leave the solar
system all together but it's not doing
that it's moving still in a circle but
way faster than it should be and gravity
shouldn't be able to hold on to it the
gravity of the sun shouldn't be able to
hold on to it so the only explanation is
that our mass for the Sun or our theory
of gravity is wrong it has to be one of
those two things that's an error
so certainly we're open-minded to both
as possibilities and the same thing is
true for the Galaxy there is kind of the
the center of the Galaxy where there's
millions of stars or billions of stars
in fact all within this Central bulge
and stars like the sun
orbit around that at tens of thousands
of light years away and we orbit around
and I guess the observation is that the
Sun and other stars like it are moving
too fast they're you know they given
their speed they should all be flying
off that they should be going off in a
tangent so there's either more there's
more gravity there than we thought there
was or a theory of gravity is wrong so
it's in relationship to the Sun and or
is it in relationship to other
other planets or other
other
exoplans or whatever the things would be
spinning around it is it in relationship
to those or relationship to the size of
the sun
that you're saying it's it's not really
the sun basically doesn't really uh we
don't have any evidence for dark matter
in terms of the sun
um the we think that dark matter is too
diffuse to get bound to solar systems
it's kind of we think it's this kind of
very light fluffy stuff that doesn't
really concentrate in the same way that
ordinary matter does so it's like a big
fluff cloud in the Galaxy so the
evidence is really by looking at
galaxies not planets
um not individual stars but the Ensemble
of stars and when you look at all of
those stars going around the center of
their Galaxy you see collectively they
are all moving quicker than they should
be in our own Milky Way it's a little
bit harder because you know we live
inside the Milky Way so how can we see
what's going on from the outside we
don't have that perspective but there's
completely independent evidence for Dark
Matter there so actually one of my
colleagues in my department Catherine
Johnston leads this work Professor
Catherine Johnston and we notice there
are these
um mini galaxies these dwarf galaxies
and even smaller than that just clusters
of stars which all bit around the Milky
Way they're very distant but they're
orbiting around us and instead of going
around in a nice compact ball of stars
they're being shredded into like
spaghetti and being stretched out into
streams of stars now we think we
understand when that happens if you
think about a black hole if something
falls into a black hole you might have
heard of the effect of spaghettification
because the gravity is so strong it it
pulls you apart so if you were falling
feet first into a Galaxy into a black
hole your feet would be close to the
black hole and so they'd be pulled down
harder than your head and so this would
actually stretch you and that's that'd
be very painful death of course to go
out that way but maybe better than
falling into the black hole in some
respects
um so we think that's probably what
would happen if you fell into a black
hole and we see the same thing happening
to these Stars they are being
spaghettified but they're really far out
from the from the milk away so by all it
counts they shouldn't this shouldn't be
happening to them but so there's
obviously way more gravity than there
should be which is again a very strong
indication that there is dark matter not
just within the Milky Way But actually
completely encompassing the Milky Way
probably the volume of dark matter is
way way bigger than the Galaxy itself
probably like 10 even 100 times larger
and we have this tiny little thing we
are like the seed inside the true Galaxy
which is this giant Halo as we call it
of dark matter and that's what's ripping
apart all of these clusters so again
another completely independent line of
evidence that's very difficult to
explain and you might be able to explain
one of those things with an alternative
theory of gravity but it's very hard to
explain all of them with the same
alternative theory of gravity it just
doesn't really work you kind of have to
have a bespoke theory of gravity for
every Galaxy and every effect whereas
Dark Matter kind of cleanly explains
everything in one go so it's still we
still want to see that we still want to
collect a particle I want to hold it in
my hand right I'm sure we all do we want
to have scientists detect the actual
particle we can you know probe it we can
obviously not really see it but we could
at least know for sure it's in this
little jar and something a Pokemon
product we haven't been able to do that
but we we're convinced that there must
be something out there and uh it's
hopefully we will detect it eventually
and if we don't that would also be
amazing because it would mean we were on
the total wrong track for 50 years right
and there's something even more
extraordinary out there
yeah exactly so I thought many times
about many odd things and that's you
know sort of conspiracy okay
um and I think about like like a Sun or
a source right the source of light you
think okay we're I walk outside and I'm
outside like it's clean it's fresh it's
open it's
this is life right and then you know I
think about
what if Mars they went inside of Mars if
you're able to create a space I mean
we've even found really crazy
civilizations that have built
underground
systems where they've lived I think
there's maybe one in turkey or something
like that that goes so many levels down
so you think and then of course all the
other things about inner earth or the
moon or all these other Concepts that
are out there and crazy and I thought
you know how could they live like how
could you go inside of something and
live but what is it that what is it that
constitutes this star the sun to be able
to give us life to make me feel like I'm
outside to make me feel like I'm
breathing and I can flourish
what is it like can it be made on a
smaller scale so that it is inhabitable
inside of something and it still feels
you like you're outside
yeah there's a lot of like really
interesting things to talk about there
um so this the sun this the reason why
the sun of course produces energy is
because it's a big nuclear fusion energy
plant basically in the sky so it's
producing huge amounts of energy by
fusing hydrogen to helium that's what's
producing all the light on all the
warmth and all the energy we receive so
could you mimic
um that reaction on Earth uh sure yeah
we are we actually have already done
that we've not been able to do it in a
way that's self-sustaining like the sun
does it but we can do it momentarily in
fact just this last year the NIH has
been releasing some some interesting uh
new experiments where they've been able
to use lasers to compress
um little pellets of hydrogen and fuse
them for very brief like nanoseconds of
time even shorter than that and that
produced actually a net energy Surplus
but it's just it's just momentary so
we're going to the point where I think
maybe we can imagine nuclear fusion
reactor at some point if you want to
produce light that feels like the light
you feel in your skin when you're
outside you probably don't need a
nuclear fusion reactor to that you just
need
um like light bulbs which mimic the sun
Spectrum which is which isn't as easy as
it sounds but yeah is again probably
technically doable and then you could
power that some other way you could have
maybe a nuclear fission reactor instead
or you could have just a giant battery
or something some other way to power
that system and then if you wanted to be
inside an object
um and make it sustainable you'd have to
have an energy source to supply maybe
these grow bulbs these kind of Lights
which mimic the sun Spectrum you could
have like a hydroponic system inside
that object where you're growing plants
and agriculture inside and so that could
be potentially sustainable and in fact
there are some arguments to think being
inside is advantageous
so for instance uh if you're on a very
if you wanted to colonize space
there's a huge number of asteroids out
there and some of the asteroids actually
contain more rare earth metals than we
could ever mine on Earth by such a large
factor that you know just one of them
would be worth like a quadrillion
dollars which is way way more than GDP
of the entire planet if you just mind
one of these so maybe in the future I
know the civilizations may have already
done this they moved these asteroids and
they mine them and as you mine them you
could carve them from the inside out
because that's where all the precious
stuff would be and then if you spin up
these asteroids you make them spin fast
and you imagine you're on the inside of
that asteroid it would create like a
pushing effect because again the
centrifugal force like driving the car
around you know banking around the
corner you'd feel being pushed to the
side as I'm sure you're familiar with
and you you would uh that same effect is
like artificial gravity so it's quite
possible that asteroids could be carved
out from the inside and then they'd be
spun up and then that would create both
artificial gravity you could have a
power source they would you could grow
plants in and so it is quite possible
and obviously if you've seen the expanse
um or read the expanse books they kind
of play with that idea there's I think
some of the in places you visit in the
show are indeed these asteroids which
have been carved out that way
for a planet it's possible as well I
mean Mars one problem with Mars is that
you get a lot of radiation on the
surface uh I think you would die of
cancer fairly quickly if you lived on
Mars because the radiation level was
hitting you and so one solution would be
to go underground you could also you
know put huge cement structures above
your head but that's going to be very
expensive to do it might just be cheaper
to go underground and on the moon as
well that has been proposed there are
these Lava Tubes so even though the Moon
is not volcanically active now in its
early history it was volcanically active
and if you go to Iceland or Hawaii
there's these Lava Tubes you can you can
if next time you go to do a tour they're
really fun it's like thin tubes look
like a giant worm has sort of eaten
through the Earth and created these
smooth round tunnels and they're
naturally there on both the moon and
probably on Mars as well and those are
like cathedral-sized spaces where you
have natural protection from solar
radiation and you could hermetically
seal it off and just have an atmosphere
in there and that would be the perfect
place for a lunar base you don't have to
build any structures you just have to
seal the two ends
lunar base inside you just said it
so I think yeah being inside makes a lot
of sense and and of course the challenge
that if civilizations do that
it makes us very difficult for people
like me who are trying to detect those
civilizations because then they become
invisible to a large degree so that
would I hope they don't do it but I can
imagine good reasons why they might do
it right well it seems like it would
check a lot of lapses it's consistent
it's predictable it's safe I mean you
know I'm guessing that the
extraterrestrials are looking at us as
I've seen the funny memes of like nah
they're still trying to kill each other
down there not yet like
you know they're still living overground
what are they thinking yeah
so volatile
it'll burn to
we have that have that level of
intelligence to comprehend a way to
engineer that I think speaks volumes
which and is just a very exciting thing
to think about and I've often wondered
though when we talk about talk about
science and you talk about gravity and
you talk about is it do we need new
Gravity or new new math or new a new way
to look at things based on where it is
we're looking and
you know with the evolution of science
here I I wonder if as we
evolve Consciousness and if we evolve
um as a species do we reach a new level
of
math like is do we break through into
another dimension which maybe then we
should talk about Dimensions first and
and what you know about that and and and
then is that part of evolving is that we
sort of go okay this this doesn't work
anymore it's too simple for our level of
awareness and and and where we're at and
we need we need new science now we need
new new numbers yeah I I worry about
that a lot as well that there are it's
the things that we we think we
understand so much but it's the things
that we can't even comprehend that we
don't understand that maybe out there
beyond our reach and the things that we
think are impressive may not be I mean
in kind of a Star Trek fan I remember
um the kids at school in that show
they're learning calculus there's like a
throwaway line in one of the episodes
where like the five-year-olds learning
calculus and twists that's just like
what the fiber can do calculus that's
crazy that may and maybe imagine what
those kids are capable of as they get
into the the higher education I really
want to quote I have to I'm just going
to steal this it's Neil deGrasse Tyson
yep because he says it's so beautiful
it's a full credit to Neil for for
saying this but he says it so
beautifully on this uh YouTube clip
about how imagine you know our
intelligence level compared to a
chimpanzee we are less than one percent
difference in genetic material right so
one percent difference in DNA that's it
and from that one percent difference you
go all the way from the most simple
tools of like sticks and rocks and maybe
barely even that with chimpanzees and
some kind of sign language like you can
get the smartest chimpanzee in the whole
world and teach it sign language and you
roll it in front of scientists and we
all kind of applaud like wow Isn't that
cool my my five-year-old can do sign
language and this smartest chimp can do
that now imagine you go in that same
direction again another one percent
along that Vector of intelligence just
one percent difference from us that
intelligence level would be so so
different that we will be you know
rolling in front of them as smart as
human beings like Albert Einstein
Stephen Hawking and they'll be doing
astrophysics in their head and they'll
be they'll be like laughing at that
thinking oh isn't that cute like my my
four or five year old has is starting to
do astrophysics in their head and their
smartest individual can just do that and
then that makes you wonder that all the
stuff that we think is impressive like
the James Webb Space Telescope and all
the you know the Silicon conductors
we've built the transistors the iPhones
all that stuff that we think is
technologically impressive is just
basically garbage to them
like circles in a circle hole as a
square goes in a square
it's the sort of thing that kids are
doing for fun like just messing around
with stuff outside and so that uh that
that worries us because
um to those civilizations uh they
probably have very little interest in US
whatsoever and we would be like the ants
right I mean you don't stop and try and
have a conversation station with an ant
in the street in fact you you really
don't even feel any sympathy for them if
you tread on them at least most people
don't or if you you know if you wanted
to build a building and there was an ant
hill in in the construction site no one
would like care they would just knock it
down and put the building there and I
think that's the case we kind of worry
about is it's not that they're malicious
malevolent to us
it's just that they really don't care
about us because we're just so unevolved
compared to them that it wouldn't even
cross their mind twice to delete our
planet if that was in the way of them
doing some project they're interested in
doing so I think that's a little bit uh
more terrifying
um but I don't think it's very likely
we're going to hear from those people
you know I don't think they're going to
be trying to communicate with us
probably the ones that are going to
communicate with us are the ones that
actually if anything are a similar level
or even behind us I kind of have this
crazy hypothesis that I think the most
likely communication will have will be
with a civilization on its way out one
that's desperate we listen but we do not
communicate really much into space we
don't have an active program of sending
out messages saying hey we're here can
please come hang out with us there isn't
uh there's a few individuals which are
interested in doing this around the
world but it's pretty controversial you
know Stephen Hawking famously hated the
idea of doing meta he thought it was
crazy dangerous we should definitely not
be sending out messages we should just
stick to our own uh World until we've
sort of got very mature but I think
Stephen Hawking might have changed his
mind if we're a civilization that was on
the verge of collapse and and we knew in
the next hundred years with fairly good
certainty this is it we are just not
going to survive in 100 years we're done
and so we might in that case be more
compelled to send out messages asking
for help because what's there to lose if
you're gonna die anyway yeah what's
what's the loss in sending out a cry for
help and so those civilizations I think
are the ones we're going to hear from
first they're not the ones that are
super Advanced you've got to all solved
who are these Galactic club members who
are super benevolent they're the ones
desperate who have gone through nuclear
Wars extreme climate change whatever it
is and they are just pleading pleading
into the dark and maybe it's not even a
plea but just a uh just a message to say
hey this was us like this is what we did
this is who we were we just don't want
to be forgotten forget us yeah yeah
we have resources of some kind on this
planet which I think is some of the some
of those conspiracies of ancient times
of what brought certain civilizations or
certain extraterrestrials to this planet
because there was certain elements
things to mine for them here on this
planet that they needed for theirs yeah
I mean the thing is with resources is
that this the Earth is not particularly
uniquely endowed with any special
resources so it becomes a little bit
hard to understand why someone would go
to so much effort to come to the Earth
We're a fairly ordinary planet in terms
of our composition I mean Mars and Venus
have basically the same composition as
the Earth and indeed that's true you
know you can look at all the asteroids
um they're they're richer in those
elements in fact but they have the same
basic stuff in them in fact if you're
gonna if you really wanted to get as
much rare earth metals or whatever it
was as you wanted an asteroid would make
far more sense as I said this is way
easier to extract that material than
from a planet
um the only case you might make as well
Earth has water so that seems somewhat
special but you know Europa Enceladus
Mars and many of the you know Pluto even
and many of the icy moons all have
plenty of ice and water as well and
that's just the solar system why would
you travel
uh you know hundreds tens of light years
across space to get water when it's one
of the most abundant things in the
universe it doesn't it doesn't make a
lot of sense so I think it's hard to
find any if we had a very unique in Star
Trek there's like deuterium again come
about to start it's like this unique
thing they use for their star drives
called deuterium only a few planets have
um and so if we discovered something
like that I'm pretty sure that doesn't
exist because it's a Sci-Fi concept but
if we did discover something maybe it
would make more sense why the Earth
might be uniquely uh useful
the most useful material we have is life
that's the most special thing about
Earth I mean we we clearly are a planet
completely governed with life and that
appears to be at least unusual maybe
extremely rare and that that is
potentially much more uh of a I don't
know how that would be a resource but
it's potentially much more valuable and
unique than any
um anything you could dig out the ground
how are we any different now
from our sort of primordial soup that
is believed to be our original
ingredients like the ingredients of the
universe
from as far back as we know which that's
also another question is we're twice as
old of a universe as we thought we were
well that was claimed recently I I think
that's probably not true but that was
claimed recently but we can just a
little off
um yeah just after a factor of two
that's yeah two astronomers that's not
that bad actually okay
order a magnitude you're okay
um let me take the first one first how's
life changed the actual uh stuff that
life uses
um it's difficult to know whether we're
using different elements or different
you know atoms and molecules than we
were when life began because no one was
there we don't have any biological
samples of the very first life we don't
even really have any fossils of the
first life and of course even if you do
have a fossil once you go through to
sort of stromatolites like the first
fossils you start to see
um that's just an imprint right so
there's no actual biological material
you can sample to really figure out the
true
um full chemical abundance of those
organisms but I suspect it really hasn't
changed that much it's just sort of
rearranging this the same kind of stuff
in more and more intricate and elaborate
ways it is interesting I think that life
has got more complex over time that's an
you know because normally in physics
there is a process of going towards more
disorder we call this entropy so if you
build a sand castle like a very ordered
structure and you you know you walk away
from it come back the next day it won't
be there the wind will have withered it
away or the ocean would have washed it
away and that tends to be the way the
universe it just wants to get rid of
structure and complexity and it just
kind of wants to make everything
homogeneous and boring and flat and that
that's kind of tends to be the laws of
physics whereas evolution is almost the
opposite you know for four billion years
there has been growing complexity in the
in all of the strings of life
that's really an interesting feature of
life it seems to fight entropy
inherently which is something that Irwin
Schrodinger who developed a lot of the
quantum theory he wrote it he wrote a
tree ties about life he pointed that out
it's kind of an interesting feature of
life
um and then this this growth of
complexity it's gone through of course
many different stages I'm not a
biologist from evolutionary biologist
but certainly we think about it when we
look for life elsewhere I think to me
the most profound thing about the story
of life is that you know we are looking
when we look at other exoplanets for
signatures of things like oxygen
uh things for like methane things that
life produces on this planet
and oxygen is produced by photosynthesis
but photosynthesis is a relatively
recent evolutionary development so it's
only about one and a half two billion
years ago I think that we started to see
photosynthesis develop and oxygen only
start to get into the atmosphere at
significant levels around about a
billion just over a billion years ago
and so the Earth is four and a half
billion years so you have about three
billion years where there was nothing
even on the surface there was no
multicellular life there was no plant
life everything was single-celled and
everything was living in water or in
oceans but the whole planet wasn't water
right but the only life that there was
was in water correct yeah life hadn't
made its way unto land as far as we can
tell until uh not too not too long
before the Cambrian explosion when life
really started to propagate onto land he
started to get plants and trees and
things like this and so it seems like
the vast majority of Earth's history
there'd be nothing really to look for
and yet we were a that was how life
spent most of its time in terms of its
history and guess what there's only less
than a billion years on the clock before
we'll become uninhabitable again and so
the the episode when planets like the
Earth at least
present a detectable signature of life
is pretty brief and it's even briefer if
you consider us of course we're just
like a like a blink of an eye and that's
if you're looking for solar panels or
satellites or rocket ships or something
as your signature of life that's even
that's an even shorter period of time
that you're looking for like you have to
be so lucky to be contemporaneous with
that and so it is a it is a challenge
that there could be millions of Worlds
out there that are teeming with life and
again come back to that problem
improving life and we just can't tell
and it may be the only way to tell would
be to visit it to scoop up a sample of
water and then to like you know put
under a microscope yeah we're a long way
from doing that but that might be
unfortunately uh what we have to wait
for for getting that that convincing
evidence unless we're just very lucky
and we happen to sync up with another
civilization or something why do we feel
like we're so special there's two sides
of the coin to this there's many
astronomers have a knee reaction to the
idea of us being special and that's
that's born from history because if you
go back to you know 500 years ago it was
widespread knowledge that the Earth was
flat that the Earth was the center of
the universe that all the planets went
around the earth including the sun was a
planet back then that's where our seven
days of the week come from Sun Sunday
um Moon Monday was also a planet and so
it you know that was the that was the
the wisdom at the time that must be true
and so our knowledge increased over time
and we started to realize actually the
Earth is not the center the sun is the
center that makes much more sense and
then we realized actually no the sun is
not the center it's going around a
Galaxy but the galaxy is the whole
universe
and then we realized that wasn't true
either our galaxy is just one of many
galaxies in fact billions of galaxies
and now we're even starting to contest
whether our universe is unique and there
may be actually other universes and
dimensions and planes as well on top of
that so it's been a in a car Sagan
describes it as a great series of
demotions right so we we thought we were
the most unique special thing the
universe was built for us and and bit by
bit that that ego becoming an ant we're
becoming an ant
yeah and and it's that that is the uh
the you know the mediocrity principle
it's sometimes called or the copernican
principle that we are nothing special
there's nothing special about where we
live and so that's why a lot of people
think there must be life out there by
that by that principle but um it's a
little bit difficult with life because
you can't say uh you know what what
happens here must be typical elsewhere
I'll give you an example
um of a good use of the copernican
principle the medical principle and that
would be the planet Neptune the planet
Neptune has basically no bearing on us
whatsoever it really doesn't matter if
Neptune was there or not there we would
still be here irrespective really has no
influence on the earth and so it's not
unreasonable to look at the fact we have
two Neptunes basically Uranus and
Neptune and so the fact we have those
means that other solar systems probably
have Neptunes and you'd be right
Neptunes are everywhere the fact they're
probably the most common type of planet
in the universe we've discovered over
the last of 20 30 years so that's
correct that would be a correct use of
it but now let's try and do it for um
the Moon
okay so we have a big moon but we are
the only planet in our solar system to
have a big moon as far as we can a
relatively compared to the planet and
lots of scientists have suggested that
our large Moon might be the reason we're
here because if you didn't have the moon
you'd have much smaller Tides those
Tides may have given rise to Tidal pools
where life in that primordial suit first
got going the moon also stabilizes the
axial tilt of the earth if you took away
the Moon Jupiter takes over and Earth's
Tilt starts to go wonky all over the
place and we get these crazy seasons and
very hectic climate
um it also probably Stripped Away the
upper lithosphere when they're impacted
there was an impact that formed the moon
and without that we might not have had
plate tectonics which are fundamental to
the carbon cycle and which life requires
so there's many reasons why we think
okay having a big moon seems important
for our existence and so in that case
you can't say
the fact we've got a moon like that that
size moon at least it's about one
percent the size of the Earth in terms
of its mass uh we we can't really say
that means that all planets have those
moons because the only reason we are
here might be because of that Moon so
maybe only one in a trillion earth-like
planets have those large moons and it's
not coincidence we live on the one that
has it because we couldn't live on the
other one since they would never be
capable of life in the first place so
that's where the copernican principle
Falls over you can't apply it to things
where your existence depends upon that
thing you're talking about
so we have to be careful with it
um and that's why you know we talk about
this are we special are we unique that's
an example of what we might call the
rare earth hypothesis that the Earth
might be incredibly unusual perhaps the
conditions which gave rise to life on
this planet were one in a billion
trillion quadrillion opportunity and
therefore it's no surprise that we live
on the planet where that happened
because of course we couldn't possibly
live on a planet where that didn't
happen since no no there was no life
there to begin with so that's this is
called the weak anthropic principle and
it really obfuscates our our ability to
do statistics you can't normally with
you know statistics say you've got one
of something there's probably many you
just can't do that for life because
we're only here because life got going
and so we kind of get this kind of
chicken and egg type logical problem
when we argue about it so it is possible
that life is very unusual
um it is possible it's even unique week
within the observable universe and even
if you don't buy that it's possible that
intelligent life is maybe life gets
going everywhere but intelligent life is
an incredibly unusual adaptation that
you think about things like uh eukaryote
cells we're all made of eukaryote cells
and there was this you know the
development of eukaryotes was this
incredibly unusual evolutionary
development where essentially two
bacteria interact with each other one
was mitochondria which is sort of an
energy producing cell and it got gobbled
up by another one as it was trying to
eat it up for lunch and instead of
consuming it they started to work
together and that formed a new thing
that had never existed before and we
just don't know was that like a was that
incredibly unusual or would that have
happened anyway was that like an
inevitable thing that would have
happened at some point these are
questions we don't know the answer to
and that's why I think we should be
open-minded to the possibility that it
could be an incredibly rare set of
circumstances that to our rival when I
researched and follow my Curiosities
about all these things there are a lot
of a lot of people and and and
scientists of sorts whether physicists
or astrophysicists that I hear talking
about how
the likelihood of us being here and I
can't wrap my head around the numbers it
doesn't it just doesn't compute with me
but they're basically like it's
impossible basically there's no way that
we have the perfect amount of oxygen to
breathe nitrogen all the all the
important elements for this planet that
they stay in Balance the the likelihood
of us being here is just it must mean
that there is a God of some sort
so when you hear that as a scientist
like does any of that resonate and what
is your what is your comeback on that I
mean you've kind of laid some of it out
just yeah I mean I would say very simply
the alternative explanation to God doing
it which is is always kind of
I'm always want to shy away from that
just because it's well hey I you know
I'm not religious but I think it's a
little bit intellectually lazy to do
that whenever you whenever you encounter
something you can't explain God did that
aliens did that it's just that's not
very it's not really in keeping within
the scientific uh idea of trying to like
come up with an understanding of why
things happen in the universe it's just
like saying what magic did it and that's
not very satisfying and there are
certain questions where you do hit that
wall like you need to talk about what
caused the big bang and and you get
stuck science is stuck at questions like
that at this point we don't really have
a way of you know you go through those
yy's in the right you will get stuck
within about five or six wise pretty
much down any thread you'll get stuck at
a certain point but I think the obvious
counter is the reason you know you could
say these things are incredibly unlikely
and I think you can make a good argument
for that we don't know that that's true
um for instance you know one of these
small probabilities would be the
probability of making a protein
the protein is made of amino acids if
you put amino acids into a test tube and
wait for them to make a protein it just
never happens and the probability of it
happening is something like uh 10 to the
minus 40 which means it should just
never happen in the universe ever really
basically it's just it's such an
incredibly improbable arrangement of
these jigsaw pieces to come in the right
way it should just never happen but you
might say well you don't actually have
to have all the all the way up to a
protein you could have some intermediate
structures that sort of precipitate the
next level and that precipitates the
next level it's sort of self-catalyzing
we would say in sort of chemistry terms
we haven't identified such a pathway yet
but it doesn't mean that one doesn't
exist just putting stuff into a test
tube it for a few hours in the
laboratory doesn't mimic millions of
years of every single all the huge land
surface area of the Earth you can't
really reproduce that in a laboratory
setting so we certainly can't rule out
that the probability is much higher than
those naive calculations might suggest
but even if those numbers were true I
would still not accept that as evidence
of God because it it trivially must be
true that we live on a planet where that
success happened because
obviously we have to necessarily live on
in a planet where life got going we
can't by virtue of being life live on a
planet where there is no life so it is a
uh it's a logical fallacy to say that
you know it's it's a possibility that it
could be otherwise it has to necessarily
be so and so in a universe that as far
as we can tell is consistent with
infinite there's the observable universe
which contains around 10 to the 22 stars
but it probably goes on far far far
beyond that with enough volume basically
everything will happen once in fact
infinite number of times and so it's to
me I see no inconsistency why the event
could be in incredibly rare and we are
that instantiation of that event because
that must necessarily be true even when
you say God it's still saying something
that you don't understand and then you
have to say where did God come from you
know it's all that kind of whole
philosophical events yeah maybe
something that seems more tangible to
talk about is or philosophize is about
is the likelihood of us being in a
simulation versus a based reality it's
it's something we have taken fairly
seriously since Nick Bostrom wrote his
famous article uh proposing this
um of course it's not an old idea you
know people have been thinking about uh
even in like I think there's a Chinese
story about uh believing you're a
butterfly when you're asleep and then
when you wake up that's the dream like
what we think now is dreaming and the
dream world is the real world sort of
thing sort of playing with these ideas
of what's real and what's not this is
kind of a modern version of it and of
course it's motivated by the enormous
improvements in computational power and
especially looking you know if you play
any modern computer games they're
getting pretty close to looking like
movies at this point and so it's not a
million miles off being able to imagine
a virtual reality environment that would
be indistinguishable from reality and
the step further would be that you could
somehow upload your brain into such an
environment and you would never be able
to distinguish the difference so it's an
interesting argument like so many things
in in these kind of discussions it is a
uh unprovable hypothesis at this point
and remains you know my opinion is I'm
again pretty agnostic to it I'd say it's
possible I don't see any evidence for it
being so it does have a potential
problem that it's unprovable and
untestable
if the simulation is perfect there's no
there's no there's nothing to look for
right there's no errors in the code
anywhere if the simulation is completely
perfect then it would be basically
impossible for us to ever detect that
and so if it's not testable it's not
science that's kind of a definition of
science is that the thing you're talking
about must be testable otherwise this
belongs in you know philosophy
departments are not physics departments
that's a little bit of a get out clause
because you just say I'm not I don't
have to think about this because it's
not testable but it is kind of true that
the Bedrock of science has to be that
you can prove an argument if you can't
prove the argument then we're just going
to spend the rest of Eternity arguing
about it that's all it's going to be and
that's not really what science is
interested in doing what's to find
answers
um so I think you know my I wrote a
paper about this a few years ago and I
kind of highlighted uh that you know
in in a world where simulation
hypothesis was true and simulated
realities exist there would be one true
reality base reality that could be this
reality we're living in right now and
therefore you know maybe 10 years 20
years we'll invent this technology and
we'll create all the simulations or uh
we are one of these daughter realities
someone else has invented this
technology
and there's millions and millions of
these things
um but there's really two it's important
to like detach that there's two uh
scenarios the scenario a where that
technology is never invented either
because it's not possible
um it's not uh civilizations never have
the uh compulsion to do so it's
considered unethical in some way I mean
there are ethical problems right people
are suffering on this planet many people
suffer this planet so you are creating a
simulation of suffering for many people
and that and some people might object to
that you're creating conscious beings
that are designed to suffer that seems a
little bit pathological as an experiment
um and so that those simulations might
not ever there's a world where their
simulations never occur and so you have
you have to give that Credence as a
hypothesis the alternative hypothesis is
that you know Elon Musk and others are
right this will happen one day when
invent this technology and then if that
scenario is true then of course I agree
if that scenario is true it's almost
certain we live in a similar to reality
because it's just far more simulated
realities than they realities but we
can't say that that is true because we
haven't proven that that simulation
technology is possible or would ever be
executed even if it was possible so we
have to really wait to see what would
come in the future of technology and so
my study I wrote in this I just said we
have to give these two scenarios equal
probability footing at this point
because it is a complete unknown and
that's usually where you start with you
gave everything 50 50 odds it's just
saying like if you're going to pick a
random bottle of Coca-Cola off the shelf
is it going to be Pepsi or Coke it's 50
50 odds around if you're just blindfold
you went through the store and you know
starting from no information whatsoever
which I claim is kind of true in this
case because we're predicting the future
um we have to give these equal Credence
and if that is true there's actually 50
of your universes is true reality base
reality and then fought like one percent
over here in terms of the simulated
universe is true reality and 49.999 the
other the rest of it is all simulated
and so it's actually slightly more
likely that you would live in simulated
reality just with the present
information that we have but all of that
would flip were somebody the day that
you know scientists their glasses
of champagne because they've invented
the first true simulation that's
indistinguishable from reality the day
that happens the odds change and then
it's almost certain that we do live in a
simulated reality with chat GPT with
deep fakes I mean and then just video
games as an example there's just so many
ways that we can look and see how
something artificially created can be in
indistinguishable to to a large degree
it's only getting that way people are
still arguing about uh AGI you know
artificial general intelligence whether
what I think there's reasons to be
skeptical that the you know the llms the
large language models that underscore
what chat gbt doing are ever going to
realistically produce an AGI that's not
my field of expertise but I'm keeping a
close attention to that conversation and
there's certainly strong voice on either
side that argue that
um the technology they're using just
will never get to that point because the
training volume is so large they're
basically running out of training data
at this point they've already consumed
almost the entire Internet it's getting
difficult to imagine how you could it's
so inefficient compared to a child I
mean a child can be shown three or four
items and then easily be able to predict
the fifth whereas these llms have to be
shown you know millions of examples
before they can make a sexual successful
prediction so it seems like it's a long
way off the kind of intelligence that we
have that can learn things from very few
examples these things require a very
large number of samples and so there's
reasons for to be skeptical that that's
ever going to lead to True AGI but of
course there's alternative element isn't
any game in town there's other methods
of doing artificial intelligence and so
I guess the question is will we devise
some other method that outstrips
strategy between the future
maybe open AI probably already have
something they're working on to that
effect I suspect and so uh that that's a
question I can't really answer
um but I it's not obvious that it's that
it's demonstrably true that we are I
think we have to accept it's not
necessarily true that we are smart
enough to create something that is as
smart as us it might be true that we are
clever enough to do that but it's not
necessarily true in the same way that
it's not necessarily true that
everything the universe is
comprehensible there may be things about
this universe that we never understand
that there are just laws of physics we
never discover or truly get our minds
around why should it be that this
primate brain is capable of discovering
everything that we're omniscient I mean
that's a little bit arrogant to assume
that there's nothing that we cannot
understand there must be limits to our
comprehension and so it is perhaps
possible that this is an example of that
um or indeed you know the the social
will or impetus the political impetus us
to develop something like this starts to
you know prevent it getting all the way
to that level of development because
lots of people have very serious safety
concerns about this technology as well
so I can see multiple reasons why it's
not it's not obvious to me that an AGI a
true simulated reality is an
inevitability maybe that's just me being
optimistic and hopeful because I don't
really want that to be true I mean but I
think we I think you know just keeping
it is it is plausible that isn't that
that is not possible and and so I'm just
keeping that window open in the
discussion it'd be interesting to get
your definition of life but life being
something where you need to like feed
and you reproduce and you evolve and you
know there's
certain elements of that that aren't
possible when we take away our our
humanness which has enormous
ramifications of course in the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence if
um it may be that we are in a
transitional period
um that you know we have Humanities like
a million year old species right you
take a human from certainly a hundred
thousand years ago and take one of those
babies that was born hundred thousand
years ago and put it into modern society
grow it up and it'll be
indistinguishable from any other human
and so that's strange because
civilization only developed about 10 000
years ago so for 90 000 even longer than
that if you if you go back to the homo
sapiens you have a very very very long
stretch of time where there was very
little apparent development in our
technology or ability it's certainly not
the scale of development we're seeing in
the current ERA if you look at today
like anything you know energy usage
um Transportation uh food the amount of
food we're growing uh demographics like
the number of people born all of that's
just exploded right over the last 100
200 years
and even even further back probably a
thousand years and so that's not
sustainable right you can't just have
exponentials grow forever something is
going to change and maybe that means
there's some population collapse in the
future maybe that means we spread out to
the stars and we leave this planet all
together or maybe that means we all
download our brains into some other
platform but certainly you can't just
have
unsustainable exponential growth forever
I think that's interesting we live in a
time that I think historians if they
exist will look back and think that was
that was a very
interesting part of History where things
were really rapidly changing and it must
have been very confusing for people to
have lived in that time with so much
happening around them so fast trying to
figure out the future of what was going
to happen I certainly feel that way in
this Society yeah there's a certain
amount of entropy that does feel like is
wrapped up in that but on the other side
there's also so much growth too there's
so much polarity like so much Duality
like the equal and opposite there that's
what it feels like to me
oh absolutely yeah I mean
um it's hard as a scientist obviously we
we don't really suffer from the same
kind of polarization that we're seeing
in kind of culture wars and political
spectrum that we have in this country
and others across the world right now
um it is I think that's always what's
attracted me to it that there isn't a
there is an objective truth and in
principle uh we should all be able to do
experiments and verify that each other
each other's experiments and agree on
factual truth and it it's getting harder
to agree in society on facts right
people don't even accept facts anymore
and I'm not surprised because you go
into Facebook or Twitter and there's so
much information that disagrees with
each other striking you that you don't
have time to check all this information
and so there's so much trust and faith
you tend to follow sources that you
think are credible
um and you know there's a lot of Bad
actors out there who I'm sure some
fraction of everyone we follow is a bad
actor we just don't know what that
fraction is and probably our missed
leading us and it it's incredibly
challenging to make sense of the world
these days I feel I have two kids and I
think the world was so much simpler when
I grew up than the world they're growing
up in
um just that just the fact of you know
phones alone right kids these days are
obsessed with their phones and they're
bombarded with tick tocks and yeah I
mean we talked about sort of you know Ai
and I mean one of the one of my biggest
concerns about Ai and young people is
um it's kind of like hacking the brain I
I don't think I don't see like a
Terminator future where Skynet takes
over I think it's more like tick tock
tick tock is a hack it's like when you
go to the casinos and you see these
people just just staring at those
screens
like in in a trance and those machines
are sort of like a hack they've tapped
into some kind of uh feedback loop in
the brain that the people can't get out
of and Tick Tock has is an incredible
algorithm because it seems to be able to
reproduce that same effect
and I worry that an AI will master that
algorithm and it will understand our
brains or reverse engineer US basically
and it will find it's there's an idea
called the static tape a static tape is
the idea that there's something that you
so badly need to listen to or watch to
that you'll be willing to chop your hand
off to to keep listening to that thing
because it's so addictive there's
nothing else you'd rather do than than
have that that material being ingested
into your brain and I kind of worry
about that more that we are going to be
hacked and we're going to be uh
basically like warm goo in the hands of
whoever controls that algorithm at that
point right they can just basically get
us to believe whatever they want us to
believe
um and so science is you know Sagan said
this science is a candle in the dark
it's a way of trying to find objective
truth in the world and that's why I
think it's more important than ever the
the scientific method and the way it
thinks about how to approach the world
but it's challenged by the fact that
there are so many things to test and
prove that we're being overwhelmed right
this is you can't physically spend all
your time pursuing the scientific method
for every question there's just too many
things to to prove and it's coming at us
too fast so I don't have a good solution
for that but it's something I am
sincerely concerned about
um I interviewed Neil deGrasse Tyson
years ago and
um one of the things that he said at the
end was that
the he feared most that he didn't know
the right question to ask
right and
that is a real problem right like you
just don't know what you don't know so
I'm curious just talking about sort of
application of Science and learning and
exploring and what's really what what is
objective truth and what is not what the
hell is even objective truth to be
honest to some degree but
um but what where do you differ in your
perspectives between what you believe
about the way the universe works and and
Neil I'm not sure
um I think me and Neil would probably
have to sit down and hack that out to
figure I'm sure we have differences in
some things but I suspect we're probably
fairly closely aligned because obviously
he's an astrophysicist the same you know
Cut From the Same Cloth as myself so I
did I did have to look up with the
difference between astrophysicist and an
astronomer was I was like yeah well
people argue about that as well uh but
but yeah I think I think we
you know we could probably blur that
line a little bit and just say that we
uh probably think about the universe
very similarly in terms of we want to
have testable evidence we want to have
hypotheses that we can interrogate that
we can have independent verification of
um that could make predictions that are
testable and then
um you know use those use those tools of
science to improve our society and to
improve our world to make better
decisions to me that's kind of the
foundation of what science is all about
I I suspect most scientists not just me
and Neil would would probably feel
similarly about about that maybe they'd
reword it slightly differently but I
feel like that's kind of we're on the
same page with that it I think the
challenge is just in modern society
you can't really do it you can't go
around people say like do your own
research but you can't do your own
research on every topic this is there is
just physically too much information
hitting us to skeptically interrogate
everything and so
it is necessary to trust experts you
have to trust experts on some things you
don't if you go to the doctor
um and you know he you know he
recommends that you take a certain drug
or something you might do a little bit
of reading on that but you're not going
to go to medical school and do a
five-year degree to make sure he's
absolutely correct you just don't have
the resource of the time to verify
everything to the nth degree and so we
we live in a site where we do have to
trust experts and that has been abused I
mean there's many cases of scientists
abusing that that trust
um to for personal gain for personal you
know to sell books or whatever it is or
to get their name out there and get some
personal
credit for whatever it is and that's
happened in history many many times
there's always snake or dealers and so I
think we should be skeptical but uh but
I think we should remember that the vast
majority of scientists are in this
because believe it or not we actually
just love the subject and we love
finding out about the world all the
scientists I know
um are are driven by just those basic
questions basic curiosity questions
about how the world Works
um and so I appreciate there are there's
you shouldn't trust everybody that you
come across but if you hear that 9 out
of 10 scientists are on board with
something there's that's probably means
that it's very likely true we can never
be in sites 100 True of anything and so
the idea of even a fact you know we say
like climate change
sometimes the climate change is a fact
uh climate change we have overwhelming
evidence that it is that that is what is
happening it's man-made climate change
but you know really in science we could
never say anything is 100 and that's
unfortunately that's just the way
science is I can never say if I hold up
this glass and I drop it onto the table
I can have 99.999 confidence it will
drop to the table but I can't be totally
sure one time one experiment the glass
might go up into the sky and that would
be really interesting if that happens
um but that's just the nature of science
that we don't have absolute confidence
in anything everything is a theory that
we only ever get growing evidence for
and so people sometimes say well it's
just evolution is just a theory climate
change is just a theory everything in
science is a theory it's just a theory
with overwhelming evidence at a certain
point and there's also theories with
very thin evidence and I would say you
know aliens being uaps is one with thin
evidence whereas you know dropping a
glass and it fall into the table is one
with very strong evidence right and we
we want to improve the evidence on those
weak cases so that we can have
clarification and that's kind of the
point of science is to nail down either
way what the truth is so that's hard in
a modern society because you know I
can't if I have a question about uaps
what do I do about that I have to either
listen to government sources
um I have to or the whistleblowers for
instance I have to listen to Skeptics
who maybe feel the opposite but it's
probably unlikely I'm gonna you know go
on to the USS Nimitz for a week and
bring all my observational collecting
instruments and be able to do that
expect and devote maybe five years of my
life trying to figure out the answer to
that question and get permission to
answer that question and of course
that's true of all of us and so we have
to defer to experts and that's where the
kind of the uh you know Twitter and
Facebook and things have fed this
culture war of just being fed
iteratively the stuff that you click so
if you if you are drawn towards stories
that are convinced that aliens are
indeed the cause of uaps you're more
likely to be shown things of that ilk
again and vice versa the other way
around if you're if you're more of a
skeptic you're going to be showing more
skeptical stuff over and over again and
so it pushes people either direction is
of course we know politically yeah and
so that that's hard
social social media has made the process
of Science and science communication
both easier in some ways but
extraordinarily more difficult in other
ways you think at any point that the the
school books that you learn from when
you go are going to have to change that
there's a bit of maybe some
chatter that I've heard in the
scientific community that there's sort
of conventional scientists and then
there's some more Progressive
scientists that might be using theories
and ideas that are a little more
esoteric
do you feel that in your do you feel
that or is that just something that
maybe because I'm so interested in the
esoteric that I hear about and I
experience with the people around me or
do you think that at some point in time
you know the books will have to change
they're going to have to rewrite some
things because we because science is
evolving just as we are and we learn and
you have to you have to correct along
the way yeah I think I want to quote
Sagan here you know Sagan said science
is not a body of knowledge it's a way of
thinking science is not the words and
you know the the laws of gravity and
things like that that are printed in the
textbooks it's the it's the approach of
thinking about the world that is
redefines the scientific method and so
by its by its very Construction
it is almost opposed to uh religion in
not being dogmatic there are no Ten
Commandments there are no truths there
are no fundamental things which are
um never questionable everything in
science is up for grabs all the time by
anyone oh and that's kind of what makes
it amazing you know it doesn't matter
who your dad was how many Nobel prizes
you won
everything even that person says is up
for grabs and should be skeptically
interrogated and they don't get a free
pass that everything they say is
therefore true everything is is
questioned and so that's the power of
Science and and by definition of that
construction because there's no Dogma
everything everything does evolve
knowledge does evolve and that's
certainly true I mean if you go back to
and say like the 18th century the number
of plants in the solar system I think
was like 1314 because it included Vesta
it included Janus it included many small
asteroid objects that were being
discovered they were all considered
planets and then they put the textbook
and they said actually you know what
we're going to redefine the planet and
now uh we're going to just have nine up
to Pluto and then of course 10 years ago
or so we did it again and we ripped up
the textbook so yeah the textbook's
constantly changing because our
information is growing I mean we thought
Pluto was the end of the solar system
which it was back then as far as we knew
but then we discovered actually there's
like 10 other Pluto's of even bigger
size than Pluto beyond that and these
seed things all seem to be quite
different and you know that I don't know
I don't really care whether we call them
plants or not to be honest it's like a
rose by any of the name still smells so
sweet but there is new information and
that new information should be reflected
in the textbook so I would certainly
expect uh textbooks to evolve I suspect
there are certain things which will
never uh which are almost not um
immutable because we cannot question
them but just a very unlikely to change
so if I took like
um the second law of Thermodynamics or
something thermodynamics is something
that is extraordinarily well established
and tested and it'll be pretty strange
if you know like any conservation of
energy was totally wrong or if um uh you
know take a
quantum theory there's some of the
bedrocks of quantum theory
um such as the Heisenberg and Center
principle it'd be strange if that was
false but
um I suspect our knowledge will increase
and maybe some of those things will be
shredded up and that's the beauty of
science that it is amenable to doing so
but I think there will there will be a a
seed of truth that was true you go back
to Isaac Newton's uh principia
there are many of those laws that we
still teach in our textbooks today and
it's not that uh is is not that
knowledge stopped after Isaac Newton got
going we've learned much more since then
but there are certain truths that he
realized that are still true today as
far as we can tell and so
um knowledge is evolving I think our
textbooks will evolve but uh I hope I
hope we don't burn all the textbooks as
it's been happening in some steps of
like throwing away all this precious
knowledge because it is the
um it is the product of this
extraordinary journey of of knowledge
acquisition about the universe and I
hope you know one thing I worry about
you've got this seed Vault that I think
it's in Sweden or something
you know if you know the foundation
series they uh by Isaac Asimov they kind
of have this idea of putting all the
knowledge somewhere and I kind of feel
that way with Humanity like there is a
risk of weed us destroying ourselves
through nuclear war through
um some kind of nanotechnology or
something called Ai and so there is it's
hard to imagine what the threat could be
but there is clearly possibilities of
destroying ourselves and it may be that
there's a reset that's going to happen
and civilization gets pushed all the way
back to the Stone Age
and it just to me it'd be obvious that
we should leave some resource for those
people to get ahead of the curve because
um even if it's a one percent chance
it's not much effort for us really to
just you know make sure that information
is stored somewhere because that is the
product of billions of Minds over
history of the most Brilliant Minds
working on problems for their entire
life to try and discover things some of
that stuff will be wrong but it'll give
an extraordinary Head Start to whoever
picks that up well we're where we are
now because of people like you And
scientists so we definitely need
scientists
um but also if we are reset
um which you know we could be in what
could be called the Great reset right
now
um not knowing what that really means
but just words that float around I mean
we would need to know how to read it we
would need to know how to decode it and
it feels like there are things left
behind that we don't understand can't
decode
you know we think we know how what the
hieroglyphs mean on the you know walls
of the temples in Egypt and various
different things and but we don't we
don't really know we don't really know
how it's all made so even if we leave
something behind we still have to reach
a level of intelligence where we can
understand it which um leads me to a
curiosity I've been learning a little
bit more about lately being the like
three types of civilizations and just
sort of how Humanity evolves and so it
feels like that's you know that's
something that we need to do as a
civilization so we don't do things like
push the nuke button on each other like
that is in yeah idiotic thing to do if
we want to survive so where are we at
and what are those what are the three
types yeah I think you describe the
katashev scale so there is uh there's a
Nikolai kardashev who is a Soviet
physicist astronomer who thought about a
way to classify civilizations in terms
of their energy use which certainly made
sense at the time but since people have
challenged whether that's truly the
quantity that we should be looking at
but anyway the basic idea that he had
was
um if you look at energy growth on our
planet it's more has been increasing by
about two or three percent ever since uh
you know even really pre-industrial
times it's been increasing two or three
percent per year so if that if that
keeps going there's a certain point
where we use as much energy on this
planet as actually strikes the Earth
from the Sun
which is a lot and we we're using far I
mean probably less than a percent of
that amount of energy that strikes the
Earth it's being used right now by human
civilization and and not just uh used in
terms of solar Powers but even the
energy we'd be digging it from the
ground like fossil fuels and burning
them if you add up all the energy is way
less the amount of energy that strikes
the earth from the sun which of course
hopefully makes sense because most of
the energy striking the Earth is used by
like plant life and to walk on the
atmosphere and stuff like that so if we
used all of that energy
there'd be no plants yeah it could be in
trouble so
um they they want a bit of that pie as
well right it's not just all for us but
the idea was there was a certain point
where that would happen and obviously
civilization would have to the planet
would look very different in such a
scenario and so we call that a kardashev
type one civilization on his scale
a civilization like that would probably
have the ability to control everything
in their planet in terms of the
atmosphere the weather
um you know protect from solar storms
maybe even the geological activity and
so they would have complete Command of
the planetary domain and then going
further this growth continued of course
the only way to get more energy would be
to go into space and to build structures
off world and eventually you might try
to harvest all the energy from your star
this is why I kind of love solar power
think about Kardashian's argument if you
wanted to collect the most energy
possible
the obvious thing to do would be to
build a shell around the Sun because
that is a nuclear fusion reactor but it
is it is not only a nuclear fission
reactor with enormous amounts of fuel
and energy it is one for which
um the problem of confinement is solved
by gravity so when we try and build
Fusion reactors on Earth the big
challenge is how do you
get all that stuff into a very high
pressure and it takes us an enormous
amount of energy with magnetic fields
and things to squeeze this stuff
together and so we lose a lot of energy
in trying to create Fusion the sun does
that kind of for free thanks to gravity
so gravity just Mass I mean that's
almost like free energy in this sense
it's kind of squeezing things together
creating those pressures and all of that
energy has been released into space a
tiny fraction hits the Earth if we
harvested that that would be kind of the
ultimate amount of energy resource we
could imagine the solar system so this
idea is called a Dyson Sphere after
Freeman Dyson a physicist who first
suggested it it has evolved since I mean
we we kind of think it's probably not
very realistic that you would build a
solid structure that seems unstable it
actually had a solid structure around a
star all you'd have to do is give it
like a little Boop like a little push
and the whole thing would just fall into
the start yeah it's not very stable so
that seems like a problem it'll actually
be much easier if instead of building a
giant structure you had lots of little
uh satellites that almost formed like a
swarm and they all orbited around the
star that'd be far far more stable than
and you wouldn't need any kind of super
strong materials or anything either so
uh yeah you could certainly imagine
harvesting one of that energy and we
have actually conducted experiments to
look for those structures I want to
point to work by colleague of mine Jason
Wright at Penn State
and they've surveyed about a hundred
thousand galaxies looking for Galaxies
which have basically been all of the
stars have been enshrouded with these
Dyson spheres and they don't find any
and something there's been work looking
for about a hundred thousand ish stars
in the local Galaxy asking if any of
them have these Dyson spheres and none
of them seem to do either that's kind of
it that's interesting because you know
this is apparently as far as we can tell
if you wanted to generate that amount of
energy this is the obvious way you would
do it maybe at a certain point
civilization is good enough and they're
like we don't need any more energy but
obviously energy for us has always been
the enabler if you want to
um lift a rock from the sea level to to
the top of Everest
there's a fundamental amount of energy
that that you know the potential energy
change that dictates how much you have
to do to do that and it's not really a
question of efficiency no matter how
efficient you you do it it's always
going to take at least that amount of
energy so the amount of work you want to
do is always going to be restricted by
your energy availability so I think it
certainly makes sense if you want to do
amazing things in the universe you're
going to need that amount of energy one
day
and the final step to this is a cutter
Chef 3 which I kind of already alluded
to which is when you basically you
harvest all the energy from the Galaxy
we don't see any evidence for those in
the local universe that is interesting
that those don't exist uh apparently
don't exist uh it may be that they are
very clever in masking those signatures
and we're not able to detect them but
again this kind of comes down to
thermodynamics and and waste heat it's
kind of the same as like your laptop
your laptop takes in power from you know
the from from the outlet in the wall
from its battery and it uses that to do
some kind of computation and then that
computation produces waste heat and
that's why your laptop feels warm on
your on your legs if you touch it and
there's no way around that if you do any
work as far as we understand with the
fundamental laws of physics whenever you
do work which is to say you're using
energy to do something useful yeah if
you're not using energy to do something
useful I mean what are you doing
um you're just not doing anything you're
just sat twirling your thumbs but if
you're doing work to do something and do
something useful
then you always have to produce this
waste energy and so it should be
detectable energy is obviously something
we can we can look for in the universe
and so I think um it would be uh it's
kind of strange that we don't see these
you should Harvest that we need to
harvest the waste energy right I mean
people always say that but the problem
with waste energy is it's it's
um it's not usable yeah it is kind of
like garbage so you can basically only
if you want to build a computer or any
kind of energy harvesting machine or
machine to do work I should say which is
useful useful energy extraction it's
always governed by temperature
differences this is called the Carno
cycle in thermodynamics developed by an
end I think an English engineer who just
you know was working on the
thermodynamics in their sort of 18th
centuries were going way back and
basically the amount of energy you can
extract is always given by two
temperature reservoirs so in our case
the temperature Reservoir is the sun the
sun is about 6 000 Kelvin the Earth is
about 3 300 Kelvin and so there's a huge
temperature difference and so that that
temperature difference allows us to
extract a huge amount of useful energy
which is how solar panels work if the
waste energy if I then use that waste
injury for my laptop the where Century
comes out at about 300 Kelvin again so
now you've got no temperature
differential and so you can't do useful
work if you built another shell further
out where you know you get down to where
Space is really really cold
then sure you could do work there it'd
have to be a gigantic shell to do that
but then again you're going to make
waste energy that would now be even
colder and again would be even sort of
more useless so it's kind of a
unavoidable fact that um once you if you
if you're doing Pro I mean probably the
best place a computer would live in
space would be the very depths of space
that's far away from a star where it's
cold as possible that's why we build our
data centers in you know the Arctic and
Antarctica and these polar regions
because where it's coldest you get the
highest efficiency for your computation
so the same way
um it's interesting to think maybe the
place to look for super Advanced AI
intelligences would be in the depths of
space very very far from Stars where you
would where you would maximize that
temperature differential and be able to
extract the most useful work energy for
longer you get more bang for your buck
out of the energy yeah yeah I wanted to
ask you only one more question but then
he said Antarctica there
other than the fact that you just told
me that they build huge computer
bases in Antarctica I mean I I don't
know the Antarctica what worries me
about Antarctica is just the amount of
ice sheet that we're going to lose off
that damn thing as the planet warms up
so I do worry about the huge ice
Reservoir that we are slowly chipping
away on on that thing it could be
obviously uh useful for computation I
think some data centers are trying to go
up there it is useful in astronomy
because
um the polar regions you know you
probably know this but uh if you're in
the Arctic during the winter you get
like not quite six months but you get
many months I think three or four months
of complete darkness and so that's
useful to astronomers if we want to you
know collect a video of the sky and
observe the sky it's kind of annoying
when it's daytime Because unless you're
doing radio astronomy you can't observe
the sky anymore whereas an Antarctica
Antarctica an Arctic you can uh you can
observe for many many months
continuously so there has been efforts
to build large telescopes in those
regions unfortunately uh they've they
they often really struggle with the
extreme conditions because you know it's
kind of strange that our technology only
seems to work at room temperature which
is maybe not a coincidence but basically
you know whatever we build down there
kind of gets gummied up with ice and
stops working in Fairly short order so
we've we don't really have any very
large successful uh surveys down there
which have really changed the game but
it is an extraordinary opportunity
perhaps as we improve our ability to
build structures in those kind of
climates that we could have access to
the sky in a way that we don't currently
have it's also good for getting around
starlink you probably know starlink is
an enormous problem because it produces
a lot of light pollution for astronomers
looking at the sky but Starling has
basically no coverage over Antarctica
because there's no customers there so
there's no satellites really there's
very very few compared to around in
North America and so it's a good place
to escape the satellites the satellite
like pollution as well well I guess we
were doing something wrong then having
starlink at Burning Man so that we could
have some cell phone service so but
whatever yeah what else you can do I
mean they're already up there so I mean
yeah I totally understand but it's uh I
hope you weren't washed out by by all
the weather it just made it more
interesting to be honest like memorable
right you'll never forget that one
you'll never forget the 23 you know
flood basically I had that with
Glastonbury one year yeah back in the UK
we had a similar year where it was just
like up to your knees but I think it's
probably even worse at Bennett because
you guys aren't used to it but uh yeah
it was interesting memorable experience
yeah exactly is the last and very worth
going to I've heard it's amazing
yeah I've loved every time I've been
there it's been incredible I haven't
been there for probably like eight nine
years though so I'm not sure if it's
evolved since when I was going regularly
but it the music is absolutely
incredible there and the the energy it's
wonderful it's the best UK Festival in
my opinion yeah yeah yeah Burning Man is
is a special one too if you've never
been it's
it's very unique very cool and something
to see it's pretty ineffable you have to
cancel it's on my bucket list yeah you
have to really see it for yourself I
just wanted to ask one more sort of
curious question and I know I'm going to
kind of stretch you as a scientist to
sort of give an opinion but based on
parallel universes multiverses all the
different potentials
um simulation Theory
based reality
like if you were to sort of put pen to
paper and go this is how I want our
reality to actually be like this is what
I I hope that we discover for Humanity
and for for the way things really are
like what would you hope what would be
what would be what would be written down
there's so many
um technologies that I wish would exist
and would be potentially transformative
to humanity I think you know Star Trek
does a really good job of laying out a
template of what some of those
Technologies might look like things like
the replicator a way to basically 3D
print food and remove the food crisis
having fusion power or some other you
know like the antimatter engines they
have in Star Trek some of the energy
source that could remove our dependency
on burning fossil fuels and damaging our
climate and you know the more advanced
ideas of being able to travel between
the Stars I mean that's when I lived up
at the stars that's what I wanted to do
I didn't just want to look at them I
always imagined that one one day I might
have the opportunity to visit them and
step foot on those other planets and you
know growing up I've realized that's
less and less likely to be true
but it's something that I think has
always driven us as a species is to
explore the next Frontier and go to the
next World and see what's around the
corner
um so if there was a way for us to
travel between the Stars one day and yet
at the same time uh protect our home and
and give everybody uh you know a fair
and equal chance of life
um I that would be my bright future I
would hope for I know that's a tall
order to ask for all of those things but
um you know the the amazing thing about
the human mind is that there might be
limits to our comprehension but as far
as we can tell there's no reasons why we
can't solve many of those problems that
I've described
and so I'm always Blown Away by the
Ingenuity of my colleagues and people in
other fields of these brilliant people
who are trying to push the envelope in
so many different ways and it gives me a
lot of Hope
um for the human race that we can think
of our way out of these problems and uh
ultimately as long as we believe that I
think it's true I think the moment we
stop believing that we can solve our
problems is sort of the end of the road
for us as a species
um and so I think it's important that we
uh we keep that faith that we can get
ourselves out of this problem and we
certainly have a lot of historical
precedent to believe that we are smart
enough to to get a to lift our species
out of this and what what an incredible
future could lie ahead for Humanity if
we do
what a time to be like
thank you for all your hard work thank
you for the time today I agree with that
reality I hope the same
thank you for having me thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today I hope you enjoyed it if
you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
Subscribe button